foreign
task for John Ellis from the canal and
River trust removing dead fish from the
Grand Union Canal near solihull
here weren't enough to save them it's
just one incident of dozens across the
country over the past few weeks and
evidence of the impact of temperatures
that the Met Office has confirmed
delivered the UK's hottest June on
record it's been an unprecedented month
what we're seeing is dissolved oxygen
levels in the water that are so low that
they can't support fish life
and we think issues almost certainly
caused by the ever increasing
temperatures that we're seeing it's
damaging our Wildlife because not only
the fish themselves but the birds that
and mammals that rely on fish your
herons your Kingfishers your Greaves and
your otters will all suffer if we don't
have healthy fish populations in our
waterways